Hey, how's it going bros. My name is PEWDIEPIE!
and today I am here
with a very special guest,
Banana.
(*In Marzia's mind* are you freakin kidding me pewds)
I made this joke so many times.
*laughter*
Marzia: Yeah.
Welcome to the show,
CutiepieMarzia.
Marzia: Thank you.
(MUSIC)
What a beauty.
What a-What a-
Marzia: Lets get into the game!
Pewds: I'm sorry Iets- *laughter*
Marzia: It's so hot in your office, man.
What's the matter with you?
Pewds: Deal with- oh God!
Don't play, I lost my controller. Don't...
Marzia: Heh.
Pewds: Don't, I'm left!
Pewds: This is the sexiest game of all time -ooh
Two men just-
(Death and laughter)
Well I guess I'm gonna go as well.
Bernie killed himself.
(STAR WARS MUSIC)
Pewds: Hey, I don't want to smell your armpit-HEY! Let go of my hair, that is the only piece of hair I have
NO
(Marzia's laughter)
Pewds: Argggggghhhh!
God damn it, Bernie, you're just jealous,
I got more hair than you.
HEY.
Pewds: Oh my god,
Marzia: Are they laughing?
Pewds: NOOOO
OH! (kissing sounds and Unknown sounds)
I love you!
(Marzia shrieks)
Pewds: OH, WHAAT?
What? How did you do that?
(Church bells)
Pewds: Oh God, no.
Marzia: DO IT.
Pewds: Please!
Please, Marzia, save me!
Don't let Edgar get my Youtube money!
Marzia: boop
Pewds: Nooo
Marzia: Is he crying?
Pewds: He IS crying, it looks sad, doesn't it?
Pewds: Hey Marzia, Why don't you come over here to this truck? What's up?
WHAT'S GOOD? Come here girl, what's sup?
Marzia: Booom, I tried.
Pewds: GOOD JOB, BRUH!
Pewds: (laughing) Oh my god!
(both laughing)
(Marzia laughing)
Pewds: How do you do that? (laughing)
Marzia: Oh!
Pewds: Oh! What are you doing?
(Laughter)
Pewds: Your character's trying to
HEY, no, don't.
Oh my god, you're crazy.
Marzia: Help me -nooo!
Pewds: What are you do-
AHHHHHHHH
Pewds: Grab my foot, trust me. It;s gonna go great.
Marzia: Noooooooooo!
Pewds: Noooo!
Pewds: Nooo...
Whyyyyy?
Marzia: You should've done th-
Pewds: Nooo..
Marzia: WOAH, the chair..
Marzia: Noooo
Pewds: NO! How did you get me?
Marzia: GO!
Pewds: What the hell is THAT!?
That's BULLSHIT!!
Marzia: In your face!
Pewds: Every time.
Marzia: Yeah go. Go.
You always lose.
Marzia:(blows air into the microphone)
Marzia: No, NO!
No..
Pewds: Hey!
(Marzia laughing)
Pewds: What are you doing, you crazy?
I got expensive equip-
Marzia: You want it in the ear?
Pewds: HEY!
Give me that.
Marzia: No!
Pewds: Epic troll Marzia
Epic Troll Marzia: Hah, har, got you in the ear!
Pewds: ENTER THE FLAMES!
Marzia: WHY?
Pewds: Cast her into the FLAMES!
No!
(Sex noises)
Pewds: How is it possible?
Ugh, yes!
You were the chosen one!
You were supposed to bring balance to the force!
Marzia: I thought I got you -oh!
Pewds: Every time.
Pewds: Ugh, I'm knocked unconscious.
Marzia, I need your help!
What are you doing? NO!
Marzia: Go!
NOOO!
Pewds:(laughing) I got your tail!
Where are you going? Oh!
Oh, ow SHIT, my head!
I'm out of this, she's crazy!
She's a fricking psychopath.
No, nonono, she's got a shortcut!
Ugh, God, so many stairs
C'mon, hurry, no!
Ugh, faster!
No, please, please, please?
Hyup! OH NO!
What happe-ahah,ahah, no!
AHH PLEASE!
NOO PLEASE?
Please?
NOOOoo ah
Oh thank God!
Marzia: I can never kill you!
Pewds: That freaking hurt!
Pewds: L-let me go Marzia, no.
No.
Thank you.
Ah, thank God!
Fu-NOOO!
No, no
Marzia: No! No!
Pewds: NOOOO!
Pewds: Yeah! HEY!
What the hell?
No, oh, OH, OH
Pewds: What are you doing?
No, don't fall down, don't fall down
I'm serious, don't fa-Marzia! Marzia, please!
Please, don't...stop!
There's a skyscraper right underneath us. I'm going for it.
Marzia: What?
Pewds: That was higher than I thought!
Pewds: Yeah I like that booty. That booty make me
Marzia: I'm dancing!
Pewds: Make that booty drop!
Marzia: Look at me, I'm dancing!
Pewds: Oh God, the signs are coming.
Yeeah!
Marzia: Booty, booty, booty booty.
Pewds: Yeah!
Oh God, it's on my side!
Duck!
YEAHH-hahaha
Marzia: Woo hoo!
Pewds: Your hair is going crazy, yeah!
( Gets hit by the sign)
OOOOHH!
(laughter)
Noooooo!!!
What the hell is that?
Marzia: I won everything in life!
Pewds: No! No, noo!
Oh, oh no.
Why?
Marzia: It's okay, Pewds.
We know you did your best, and it wasn't good enough.
It's okay.
Marzia: So, yeah!
Pewds: I can't talk. You do the outro.
Marzia: Um, like and favorite if you enjoyed!
Is favorite-ing still a thing?
No? Just like this video,
subscribe for more!
And Pewds is gonna cry in a corner.
(sounds of abuse on a toy)
Marzia: Wow.
You better go, bro-brofist!
How you do the brofist? I'm gonna fall!
(Another video and outro music)